Всім привіт! Мене звати Анна Домніч
І саме зараз час трохи розім'ятись після навчання
Я думаю, що кожен із вас знає, що
спорт — це сила, краса та здоров'я
І це дуже корисно для нашого організму
Пропоную вам доєднатись до
наших драйвових руханок
і зарядитись позитивом.
Розпочинаємо!
Привіт, друзі!
Ну що, ви готові до нашої шаленої руханки?
Я пропоную розпочинати
У нас в гостях сьогодні Олександр Усік
і Наталя Годунко
Дивіться! В мене сьогодні суперталановиті гості
В принципі, як і завжди, але ці — особливі
Тому ми разом з вами потанцюємо, порухаємось
Я сподіваюсь, ви вже готові
Всі стали перед своїми екранами
і ми можемо розпочинати
Перед тим як ми будемо танцювати нашу руханку,
я хочу вивчити з вами один найскладніший рух
Ви готові, друзі?
Нам треба стати.
Хто знає, яка це позиція ніг?
Шоста
Прекрасно! Шоста позиція
Давайте повторимо.
А першу хто знає?
Дивіться, перша.
Перевіряю виворотність
Наскільки ви можете виворотно стати?
Давайте, Ви нам теж покажете
І я обов'язково покажу свою
Друга
Раз, вийти в другу позицію
І давайте вийдемо ще у третю
Четверта
Вперед
П'ята
Максимально виворотно,
наскільки ви це можете зробити
Ще можна ось так зробити, хто хоче
Шоста. Прямо
Ми готові. Стали у шостій позиції
Зараз нам треба буде з вами стрибнути
Одна ніжка на п'яточку, а друга на носочок
Раз, два
І знову в шосту позицію, два
В іншу сторону — раз
Два
Раз, два
Здається, наших рук не вистачає
Мені здається, що треба додати руки
Ми так ось сьогодні будемо ще танцювати
Добре
Але тут додамо сюди ручки
Раз, ніби б'ю свого напарника
І зібратись, два
Ще раз
Два
Раз
Вийшло?
А давайте трохи швидше!
Давайте
Раз, два
Нічого собі, який у вас темп!
Навіть я так швидко не можу
Ну що, ми готові під музику?
Так? Давайте
Починаємо ми з чого?
З того, що опустились вниз.
Добре
[лунає музика]
Дихаємо
Вдихаємо носиком, видихаємо ротиком
Друга ручка
Олександр, Ви усміхаєтесь?
Я дуже усміхаюсь
Ми ж нічого не знаємо, що будемо зараз робити
І-і-і
Вперед
Ще раз
На місці
І кожен як йому подобається
Раз, раз
Супер! Молодці
Наш улюблений рух, ми готувались
Так
П'ять, шість, сім і...
Раз, раз, раз, раз
І готові дихати
Права ручка
Ліва
Дві
Раз
Плескаємо собі через те, що ми такі круті
Навхрест
Вперед
Кожен як йому подобається
Ще раз
Вперед
В сторони
Дихаємо
Так і хочеться танцювати!
Ще більше
Так, ще більше!
Плескаємо
Наш рух
Раз, раз, раз
Ви так швидко-швидко
То давайте ще швидше!
Швидше-швидше!
Ще раз
Плескаємо
Ще
Готові до свого фінального руху?
Ой, не знаю! Ух!
Клас! Друзі, ви такі молодці
Давайте п'ять. Дякую вам!
[лунає дзвінок]
Друзі, я сподіваюсь, вам теж сподобалось
Ви розім'ялися і ви готові вже
до свого наступного уроку
А ми вам дякуємо.
До зустрічі!
Бувайте! На все добре!